مشاركه هي الادنى في تاريخ الانتخابات
التونسيه هذه النسبه واقعه لاحظناه
ولمسناه اا حتى قبل الانتخابات عندما
وصلنا الى هنا الى تونس كانت ملامح الحمله
الانتخابيه غائبه همم تماما يوم الاقتراع
عندما ذهبنا الى مراكز الاقتراع كان
الاقبال ضعيف جدا وحتى من قابلناهم واكدوا
بانهم ادلوا به صوتهم عندما سالناهم لمن
صوتهم او لماذا صوتهم قالوا بانهم حتى لا
يعرفون المرشح فقط لان لديهم امل في
التغيير عندما سالناهم عن اي تغيير قالوا
بانه يجب همم الذهاب الى ربما مرحله جديده
في البلاد لكن ربما حتى همم نشره او همم
نمثل هذه النسبه
المتدنيه همم ساعات قبل انطلاق الانتخابات
تحدثتي الى مجموعه من المواطنين التونسيين
وكان ردهم بهذا السؤال بهذا التساؤل عن اي
انتخابات نتحدث قال يعني بطريقه شبه ساخره
هل هناك اصلا انتخابات في البلاد ربما هذا
يفسر هذه النسبه
المتدنجه في هذه الانتخابات طبعا بانتظار
ما ستعلنه الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات مساء اليوم والتحديد على
الساعه السادسه مساء من نتائج طبعا ستكون
نسبه مشاركه نهائيه وايضا النتائج التي
سيتم الاعلى عنها فالدنيا ما المنتظر الان
يعني ما هي التداعيات المحتمله على المشهد
السياسيه هناك دعوات لقصص سعيد بالتنحم
قبل المعارضه ما المنتظر
عزيزه عمليه كما قلت قبل قليل هناك انتظار
لي ما ستعلنه الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في هذا السياق يعني بالنسبه
لتداعيات على المشهد السياسي نائب رئيس
الهيئه ماهر جديد قال في تصريح اذاعيه
اليوم قال بان 24 مرشحا ااه سيعلن فوزهم
اليوم لانه ربما ااه حصلوا على الاصوات
اللازمه لذلك وقال بانه مهما كانت سيتم
ارسال البرلمان الجديد في شهر مارس القادم
بغض النظر طبعا عن نسبه المشاركه وايضا عن
النتائج التي ان ننتظرها اليوم هذا رغم ان
المعارضه كما قلت جبهه خلاص حركه النهضه
الى غير ذلك من الاطراف المعارضه كانت
قالت بان هذه النسبه المتدنجه هي تنزع
الشرعيه عن همم هذه الانتخابات وايضا عن
مشروع الرئيس سعيد نحن ايضا الان بانتظار
ماذا يق الرئيسه قيس سعيد هل سيستخلص اي
دروس او اي عبر من همم هذه النسبه
المتدنيه ومن هذه الانتخابات
وايضا همم سننتظر ما سيقوله انصار يعني في
هذا السياق مثلا كان معي منذ يومين احد
انصار الرئيس قيس سعيد وكان معنا في
مداخله مباشره على قناه عندما سالته عن
النسبه المتدنيه هو لم يرد تحميل
المسؤوليه طبعا للرئيس قيس سعيد جدا
مباشره حملها للجميع هذا على الهواء لكن
عندما خرجنا من البث المباشر وهو
بالمناسبه يمثل حركه الشعب التي تساند
الرئيس لكن عندما خرجنا من البث المباشر
قال لي بصريح العباره قال لي انا محرج جدا
لان هذه النسبه ضئيله جدا هناك مشكله في
التمثيليه وقال لي يجب على الرئيس ان يضع
هذه امته مجددا امامه الناخبين التونسيين
في اقتراع في اقتراع انتخابات جديده همم
تحدث عن انتخابات
بس هي همم مثلا همم يعني هناك اصوات حتى
من داخل التيار المؤيد للرئيس ربما تدعو
الى استخلاص العبر من همم هذا الدرس هذا
بالنسبه للمشهد السياسي الداخليه خارجيا
ايضا هناك تساؤلات حول التداعيات ولاسيا
مع عزيزه ان همم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والغرب عموما كان دعا الى
انتخابات شفافه واقتراع شفاف
والتساؤلات حول نسبه المشاركه تطرح ايضا
علامات استفهام بشان همم
ما سيقوله الغرب بشان هذه الانتخابات هناك
ايضا مساله قرض صندوق النقد الدولي نعلم
عزيزه بان هذا الاسبوع او الاسبوع الماضي
يوم الاربعاء الماضي صندوق النقد قرر
تاجيل النظر في مساله القرض الذي قد يمنحه
لتونس رغم الاتفاق المبدئي الذي كان تم
التواصل اليه في اكتوبر الماضي الان وبعد
هذه النسبه المتدنيه في همم الانتخابات
فايده هناك تساؤلات هل سيمضي صندوق النقد
الدولي في منح هذا القرض التناسدا تداعيات
كبيره منتظره بالنسبه لي تونس بعد هذه
الانتخابات شكرا جزيلا لك دنيا نور مفادات
فرونس بانكيات الى تونس